نتوجه الان الى لندن العاصمه البريطانيه و
مراسلنا اسد الله الصاوي ل يطلعنا على ما
توفر من معلومات في لندن وبريطانيا تشارك
الولايات المتحده في هذه العمليه قبل
ذلك اسمح لي اساد الله ان انوه بهذا الخبر
العاجل قيادي في انصار الله الحوثيين قال
الجزيره وهو علي القحوم تحديدا يقول
باننا نرد الان بقوه على البوارج
الامريكيه والبريطانيه في البحر الاحمر
اذا هذا تطور جديد بعدما ذكر مسؤول امريكي
للجزيره بان العمليه انتهت وبان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا تحتفظان بحق الرد اذا
تواصلت التهديدات الان علي القحوم وهو
القيادي في انصار الله الحوثيين يصرح
ويقول بانهم يردون بقوه على البوارج
الامريكيه والبريطانيه في البحر الاحمر في
هذه الاثناء اسد الله الصاوي ما الذي
تقوله
بريطانيا نعم محمد حتى الان بريطانيا
الرسميه لم تتحدث بعد لم يصدر اي تصريح
رسمي عن الحكومه البريطانيه او اي حتى
مسؤول من البرلمان البريطاني عن هذه
العمليه ولكن تسريبات الاعلام البريطاني
تشير الى ان هذه العمليه اريد لها ان تكون
محدوده للغايه وان تستهدف قدرات جماعه
انصار الله الحوثي
على شن هجمات على السفن في منطقه جنوب
البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن ولكن كانت يعني
محدوده ايضا بمخاوف كبيره لدى بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده من ان يؤدي هذا العمل
العسكري اذا توسع الى تاثر حركه نقل النفط
في العالم وبالتالي التاثير على اسعار
النفط يذكر هنا محمد ان عام 2024 هو عام
انتخابات في كل من الولايات المتحده و
بريطانيا وبالتالي حكومتا البلدين لا
تريدان اي زعزعه للاستقرار
ول اسعار النفط في العالم لان هذا يؤثر
على اقتصاد البلدين الذين يتاثر بالفعل
بشكل سلبي جراء تداعيات مختلفه لاحداث
مختلفه وهما لا تريدان ان يتوسع الصراع
ايضا في الشرق الاوسط اكثر مما هو عليه
وبالتالي اراد ارسال رساله واضحه الى
جماعه انصار الحوثيين بالكف عن استهداف
السفن وبانهم سيتدخل او بانهما
سيتدخل اذا لم تصل الرساله او لم يعني
تستجب جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين لهذه
الرساله يجب الاشاره ايضا محمد الى ان
المعلومات الصادره حتى الان تشير الى
مشاركه الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا فقط لا
يوجد اي شريك ثالث يتم ذكره سواء في لندن
او في
واشنطن او عبر تسريبات وسائل الاعلام
وبالتالي هذه عمليه حتى الان ثنائيه فقط
لا يوجد شركاء اخرون للاست فرنسا مثلا كما
تردد قبل العمليه بعده ساعات بانها ربما
تشارك بشكل منفصل
وبالتالي الرساله هنا هي رساله امريكيه
بريطانيه لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
بالكف عن استهداف السفن يجب الاشاره ايضا
الى
ان محافظ بنك انجلترا اندرو بيلي كان يخضع
للمسائله امام لجنه برلمانيه الخميس في
لندن وقال بالتحديد ان تاثيرات استهداف
السفن في جنوب البحر الاحمر قد تطال
بريطانيا وتؤثر على الاقتصاد وبالتالي هو
يعني ارسل تحذيرا مبطنا للسياسيين بان اي
اضطراب لحركه نقل النفط في العالم واي
توسع للصراع في هذه المنطقه قد يؤثر
بالفعل على الاقتصاد البريطاني
المتاثر فعليا بسبب عوامل كثيره والحكومه
البريطانيه تواجه انتقادات عده باخفائها
في تعديل مسار الاقتصاد واستعاده مسار
النمو مثلا الحكومه البريطانيه في موقف لا
تحسد عليه مقارنه بالمعارضه قبل يعني اشهر
ربما من انتخابات متوقعه في عام
2024 وبالتالي هذه العمليه حسب ما قاله
الزميل فادي منصور في واشنطن هي انتهت كان
يراد لها ان تكون محدوده كان يراد منها
ارسال رساله واضحه الى جماعه انصار الله
الحوثيين رد هذه الجماعه ربما في الساعات
المقبله قد يحدد التطورات في ال الفتره
المقبله الساعات وربما الايام المقبله
ولكن من قبل بريطانيا والولايات المتحده
لا يراد لهذه العمليه ان تستمر كثيرا او
ان تتوسع كثيرا ا